[Musique]
je vous donne tout ce que j'ai
l'histoire de notre court métrage en
fait il s'agit de maele 35 ans c'est une
femme qui va acheter une voiture a en
particulier donc
yay de chevaux va devoir se rendra à
saint-raphaël
donc le soir donc quand on le découvre
pourquoi dans le court métrage à la fin
il va lui arriver tout un tas de
péripéties donc des rencontres pas mal
de problèmes des problèmes à résoudre
très rapidement
écoutez c'est ridicule mettez vos sacs
dans mon coffre clech vous ramène chez
vous vous savez ma ptite dame
c'est pas très à l'aise en veux tu
vous savez je connais pas pour nous
sauvage allez-y monter ça me fait
plaisir mais c'est pas vous attendez que
je m'arrête pour lui c'est pas dans la
voiture
non l'image qu'on avait du festival de
cannes c'est que c'est quelque chose
d'unique c'est un rêve pour tous les
les astres qui débute ce soit en
étudiant ou un professionnel très très
belle
ça va tomber regarder ses talons sont
immenses jamais on n'aurait imaginé y
aller un jour et là on a n'a pu réaliser
notre rêve quelque part des marchés
voilà on a la pression et c'est ça qui
est assez incroyable on a vingt enfin 8
19 20 et voilà enfin on est déjà ici et
à monter les marches
est ce qui est fou quand même c'est que
j'ai tellement de gens qui voudraient y
être et puis nous on a cette chance de
pouvoir y toucher du doigt et et se dire
que aux caisses accessible et en
réalisant des films peut-être qu'on
pourrait réussir à venir ici quoi voilà
puis c'est clair que ça fait sur le cv
c'est quand même vachement plus cool de
qu'on a fait la montée des marches et et
puis même si une expérience qu'ont ça
fait rêver quoi et je regardais étoiles
dans les yeux de tous les jours jusqu'à
jusqu'à la prochaine fois